all right guys so I'm in Vegas it's very
hot here I am looking this as at at
Vegas as a city to move to
um I'm I'm torn there's a lot of space
okay I really do like the space here I
think the space is amazing
being in London I'm like wow this space
is awesome however
this [__] is so hot
and I'm like how the hell
would you raise a family next to all
this craziness
but you know who knows it's not out of
the question so
I was thinking yesterday I had this
thought
as Pearl does
and the thought was
are women
are we really that smart
and I was thinking we have all these IQ
tests right that tell us women are like
smarter we're more mature than men and
I'm like
is that what I see in real life and I
just started thinking I'm like
do I really see women acting more
maturely
then man
I mean men might get into a brawl over
something stupid but they kind of work
it out we're women it's like we're Petty
to each other for like a decade
a literal decade it's like you'll see
sorority sisters that haven't seen each
other in years
talking about how
they like hate each other like 10 years
later I'm like is that really maturity
I'm like I think they just
tell us this to like make us delusional
for a lifetime and I started thinking
about our smartness and I'm like are
women
I like to think I'm a smart chick
but we can all be idiots so it's like
let me think about this if we're so
smart where is
the female Elon Musk
where is the female Bill Gates
where is the female
even I was thinking of the influencers
I'm like influencing and like monetizing
beauty is something women are better at
um just because we're hotties but I'm
like
is there a female Ben Shapiro
that's like equally as smart as him or
smarter
no no I've never seen a chick
[Music]
that recites stats like Ben shapir and
don't get me wrong there are some smart
women out there but as a group
as a collective I'm like
are we really
that smart and then I started thinking
about our decision making and I'm like
whenever we take over an industry
we just like ruin it it's so sad well
like
base everything off our feelings and
like at an HR departments and like
take away the competitiveness of
Industries so it's like and then we'll
do all these woke hiring stuff so
I'm like
wow guys I think they faked the IQ tests
and tell us that we're smarter
when we're not actually smarter I got
because it just doesn't make sense I'm
like how the hell are women smarter than
men you just you can't convince me of
this
not this is not real
they're faking it all right I think my
Uber's here so I gotta go but let me
know guys Vegas yes or no
are women really are we really that
smart
I don't see it but maybe I'm wrong maybe
hold on
Uber
yeah yeah okay
and it's like okay hold on guys
it's like if we were really that smart
why does every chick I know
have a crazy ex-boyfriend
I'm not even saying I'm special but it's
like if women are really because I was
literally thinking about this last night
I was like if women are really smarter
than men really because that's what
they're saying they're like women were
just these like big smarty pantses and
we're so smart and I just kept thinking
about it and I'm like okay if we're that
smart where is the female Elon Musk do
you know who are Elon Musk is Kim
Kardashian
that's her and then I kept finding out
about these female inventors and then I
would research them or these female
business owners and I would research
them I'd be like okay thank you these
smarty pants female business owners
oh my God
all of them their husbands did most of
the work
that's the crazy thing I couldn't
believe it I was like okay this next I
would find one chick and I would be like
okay this chick has to be the smarty
pants we're looking for this woman they
say that women are smarter than men
so I'm just looking and this is what I
think they make up these studies I
really do I think they make up these
studies I think they make up these IQ
tests
to make women feel like we do more than
we actually do
because if we really did all that we
think we did we would have the outcomes
we'd have all these smart women and then
I started looking at female CEOs
and it was like every time a chick would
like take over
they would just like run it into the
ground
and I don't say this like guys you know
I I make
a lot of money for my age you know I'm
I'm really successful for for a woman
but no even for a guy but really I think
what makes me successful
is trusting men to make decisions to be
honest because
you know
um I had to get a lot of advice from Men
and every time I have to make a business
decision I go to my dad
and I just think like if women like I I
just I literally guys I could not stop
thinking about this last night I'm like
I think and then I started researching
it more and I found out that in the 80s
um and in the last hundred years women
have really taken over education and you
know what happened when we took over
education everyone got Dumber
everybody IQ okay this was the worst
part this was the funniest part two
women now they have a teacher and a
teacher's aide
two women cannot teach the way one man
used to teach that's how bad it is like
literally the the
now of a teacher and a teacher's aide on
average in classrooms and it used to be
one man and the man used to have better
outcomes so I'm like okay can we
and then the last couple months guys I
keep trying to find something that we're
better at I literally and so I was like
okay we're the nurturing we're the
motherly ones I found out we're more
likely to kill infants and the elderly
so saying we're more nurturing is like
saying someone without a gun
oh and I don't say this to like [__] on
women I know there's great women out
but I was like as a group
are we really doing that great
are we really like and so I was thinking
like what valued are we supposed to
bring to a normal society right like in
history like women have brought value
and usually it's through children
but we're not having children and I was
like oh [__]
wow I was like like we're supposed to
have three kids each to like replace the
population that's like okay ladies you
have one job have enough children to
replace the population and we're like oh
no guys that's too hard we can't do that
so I was like okay maybe our jobs are
super important maybe like the jobs that
we do just really run Society you know
they say in the media like we have all
these like boss [__] or whatever and
but then it's like okay
when the rubber meets the road at these
big companies when these companies are
like
about to go out of business right
and they have to fire all the people
they don't need you know who gets fired
I hate to say it guys
a lot of white women in HR I'll tell you
that but no I'm serious I started
looking at it the before and after of
Elon Musk like before like he had this
really diverse group of people
and then he was like all right we gotta
make money now ladies ladies you gotta
go now I'm not saying women like there
aren't smart women that don't contribute
we totally do but like
smarter than men really and I was
thinking about the smartest women I know
all of the smartest women I know submit
to the authority of a guy
they all obey either their husband or
really smart boss
and then they become really smart
because they're like listening to the
guys
and I'm like huh
I think I'm smart because I listen to my
dad
he's the smartest person I know
and I was like do I know anyone smarter
than my dad
no
especially not a woman like sorry guys
you know
and you know I really think the problem
is we've taken away sexism I was
thinking about this we took away sexism
to the point where we're like we're
equal we're equal we're equal and I'm
like we literally cannot be equal that
does not make any sense
you know men are stronger than us and I
I'm starting to conclude they're smarter
than us too
because it's like okay can we really
trust these institutions
I mean they're telling us women can be
men and men can be women like in the
bathrooms and [__] like in England I
just went into a bathroom and they're
letting [__] in there so I'm like
okay we clearly can't trust these
institutions are saying so it's like
when the institutions bring out these
studies that oh the women are just so
smart I'm like guys is that match like
what we see in real life
and then I was thinking about all this
other stuff you're telling me women are
better at multitasking that doesn't make
any sense if women were so good at
multitasking we would build societies
we would build something like men are
the ones engineering everything
and I'm like
then they'll say like women are just
like more mature than men and I just
started thinking about it and I'm like
you know frat houses guys in frats will
be friends for life
like those guys will literally be
brothers like I remember in college my
friend um Sam was in a frat and I went
to his frat and they would have these
brothers back and they would just be
like best friends and they would all I
mean maybe they'd do some I guess
arguably immature stuff but I just argue
it's like masculine stuff like playing
games and like I mean maybe they
probably get too drunk or whatever but
like you know these guys would just you
know
hang out and be friends and if they had
a disagreement they'd fight but then
they get over it and it's like weird
guys will like fight each other and then
get over it you know they might like
punch each other then they'll be like
okay you took the punch now you're part
of the group again women it's like 10
years later we'll still be mad about
that one thing that happened like women
we get over nothing
and and I'm not even saying I'm special
I'm like there's [__] I remember I could
tell you which [__] I hated nice
and that was 10 years ago and then
they'll be like Pearl it's just you and
I'm like it's just you you just talk
like this because you're you just hate
women and like you
you
um just you don't don't speak for all
women unlike guys you know you can't
make me blind
like I'm not I'm not blind to what I see
I'm like you know all these like
sorority houses when women are left to
our own devices and we're all together
it's like what do we do
um we're [__] we're absolute [__]
but you know when when the wives talk to
each other the husband will be like you
know what honey I think you're getting
it to a little too off the rails and
they'll be like the men kind of help a
little bit but it's so funny when women
go into men's spaces this is what I
realize too they just tell men how to
talk so metal like roast each other and
that's just kind of how guys talk
they're a lot more blunt they're a lot
more direct and then the women will come
in and because we think we're so smart
we'll be like oh
Wim like men speak like women and we'll
be like oh you can't talk like that you
can't say it like that so that's what
you can tell if a man is like saying oh
you shouldn't say it like that you need
to watch your language he's probably led
by some woman in this life that he's
afraid of like I was on this podcast the
other day this guy was like oh if my mom
heard you say that well why are you like
40 or 35 and afraid of your mom
like guys that shouldn't be normal
for whip neither like it really
shouldn't be normal but I realized the
other thing that's a crazy red pill it's
not Daddy Issues they're all mommy
issues because the mothers were just we
just talk into our kids here and we just
like tell them how evil their dad is and
usually the dad isn't even that evil
um because I don't know why like women
when we're just left to our own devices
we just kind of go crazy and you see it
because you see it in in like all of the
and that's what they'll do they'll be
like study study but I'm not blind like
even Jennifer Aniston she's America's
sweetheart she's kind of going nutty
like if we if we are single for too long
and by ourselves we just go nutty I
don't know why
um but the man it's like I mean maybe
they go a little naughty but it's just
not the same like
you know I mean I think some of them get
addicted to sex sure but you know
honestly from a biological point of view
that they would have been winning like
they would have had all the kids in
history so you know
you know I mean I I do think that [__]
guys up too so I'm not I'm not saying
not but even the fact that I have to say
but guys like I can't have a conver like
it's so funny you realize you have this
gut reaction every time you say
something about women you have to say
but and then bring up whatever's wrong
with the men just to make like us women
feel better because our whole lives
we've just been told you're so special
and smart and amazing
and it turns out like from a historical
point of view we're not that special not
that smart or not that amazing and I was
thinking about it because I was thinking
about what has made women special from a
historical point of view like throughout
time right and like what you would have
reproduced the most and I was like you
had to have a lot of kids which we're
not doing you had to be beautiful which
we're really not nowadays we got this
Botox that just freezes our face and
makes us look funny and like we're not
really that healthy anymore and I'm like
wow
and none of us can really like do
anything like we don't have those
traditional like how many women can sew
and like serve the men it's like no
I'm not even saying I'm better I'm just
like I'm just looking at Trends and I'm
like wow
so yeah but it's crazy if you say women
aren't special then you're the bad guy
you say women aren't amazing like we're
actually just kind of like people
just like if you say like men
they're not amazing they're not special
nobody really bad an eye but if you say
that about women it's like ah
not women you can't go after women
so
[Music]
you know my two cents my thought of the
day
that I I just I I thought about this for
like three hours last night I was like
where is the female Elon Musk and I
started even like Madame CJ Walker the
first woman millionaire
there's some guy that was super involved
in her business but those are exceptions
they're not the rule if you look at all
the billionaire men
they're all they're all self-made all
the women just stole the money from the
men it's like Jeff Bezos his wife
uh
who's the other famous divorce side
there's like a couple but it's just not
even I was thinking Whitney wolf heard
it's like this girl they're propping up
now
she's not even the majority like owner
of the company
um or maybe like like she basically has
men run the company
which is exactly what I'm gonna do
some smart lady I see the difference
but you know let me know what you guys
think in the comments maybe I'm just not
crazy there's no validity I just hate
women I don't know
but you guys can't make me blind like
I'm not blind to what I see so yeah like
the video subscribe I'll talk to you
guys later